[Music]
probandtoroids they're obscure
counter-intuitive look strange as can be
and I absolutely love them Drex here
from drexfactor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today
I'm talking about the most obscure of
the Obscure okay so housekeeping first
what exactly is a toroid much less a
probentoroid toroids are a class of poi
tricks that are performed by bending the
POI plane on axis towards the audience
presenting the POI as a series of
straight lines rather than curves when
performing toroids we generally imagine
that the plane of the POI is in itself a
prop that we are spinning relative to
the direction that the hand is moving in
if the POI plane spins in the opposite
direction that the hand does we refer to
the toroid as an antiben toroid if the
POI plane spins in the same direction
that the hand does and completes the
same number of Beats we refer to it as
an isobent toroid
and if the POI plane spins in the same
direction as the hand and completes more
beats than the hand does we would call
this a pro Bend toroid and it's this
final case that we're going to explore
in this video because some really wild
things start to happen with proband
toroids and if all of this still sounds
kind of confusing I recently did a video
demystifying the terminology around
toroids and explaining how they relate
to normal POI flowers that I'll go ahead
and link to down in the description as
well as up in the cards if you're
watching on YouTube Okay so let's talk
for a second about what makes
probantorroids unique unlike anti-bend
and isobend toroids probantorroids do
not always result in the POI facing the
audience Edge on this also means that
they are the toroid that most closely
resembles the classical POI flower that
they are analogous to in this case in
spin flowers but why is this well let's
try to visualize it for a moment as with
all toroids the theory behind proband
toroids is that we take the POI plane
and point it at Edge on towards the
audience creating a straight line this
we can then imagine is being analogous
to another prop like a staff and when
spinning a staff inspin flowers have a
unique quality that both isolations and
anti-spin flowers do not when one
performs anti-spin flowers with a staff
the resulting pattern is filled with
straight lines likewise when performing
isolations we see a series of moments
when the staff presents a profile as a
straight line but in in spin flowers for
the first time we are seeing the staff
produce real curves and a lot of them
and yes I know that there's also Curves
in a staff isolation but when we apply
that metaphor to toroids the curves
disappear because of the way the POI
plane bends but in in spin flowers and
by extension probe and toroids the
curves don't disappear they are the only
type of toroids where we are guaranteed
to see these curves so let's talk about
how to perform a basic probendoroid as
with most of our toroids we're going to
start by spinning our POI forward and
Buzz saw plane with our hand near our
waist we're looking for a moment when
the POI head is dropping down out in
front of us and we're going to pull our
hand out to the right side and let the
POI head drop into spinning
counterclockwise in wall plane unlike
our ISO Bend or anti-bend toroids this
Bend doesn't happen when the POI is
furthest to the inside or outside of our
imaginary donut but halfway between the
two it's almost like performing a two
beat or Tic Tac pointed diagonally off
to the left the next step is for us to
take the POI into a horizontal plane as
the POI is spinning in wall plane we're
going to watch out for the moment when
it reaches the top of its path and is
about to spin inward toward our body
Center when it reaches this point we're
going to pull our hands slightly back
towards ourselves at roughly shoulder
level out to the right and switch the
POI into a horizontal plane spinning
counterclockwise if we were to look down
on it from above we'll want to keep the
POI plane just above our hands so so
make sure to have some give in your
elbow and let the POI hang just slightly
below the hand in order to keep the
plane stable as it spins in the new
plane it takes less energy than you
think it does next up we're going to
take the POI back into wall plane this
one's going to feel a little funky as
the POI is spinning counterclockwise
horizontally watch out for the moment
when the POI spins closest to your body
when the POI passes through this point
you'll want to push your hand upward a
little towards your Center and bend the
POI into a vertical plane between your
arm and your body spinning
counterclockwise relative to you this
plane orientation is pretty bizarre it's
an inside plane like we would use for an
inversion or introverted weave and it
means keeping the POI spinning in a
stable plane pointed back at ourselves I
recommend keeping your POI short for
this to avoid collisions with your arm
or other parts of your body alright now
let's take things back to a buzz saw
plane but close to our head now instead
of down below as we spin the poi
counterclockwise in this inside plane
we're going to keep an eye out for the
point when the POI begins spinning
straight down this should be close to if
not directly on our Center Line as the
POI passes through this point we're
going to move our hands slightly forward
into the center and towards our head to
switch the POI into a buzz saw plane
spinning reverse at our eye level this
is going to feel a little weird since
effectively we're bending the POI when
it's coming back at us to come even more
back at us but gets us into the vertical
position we need to be in to complete
the first half of this pattern cool so
that's the first half of the pattern now
let's learn how to take it back down on
the other side from that reverse Buzz
saw up near your head watch out for the
point when the POI starts spinning
upward towards the ceiling or Sky the
next time the POI passes through that
point move your hands slightly over to
the left side and bend the plane over
into wall plane spinning
counterclockwise yeah notice a pattern
here yet all all the segments that turn
the plane in profile to the audience
will be counterclockwise that's because
that's also the direction our hand is
moving in and now it's back to the
horizontal plane as we spin the POI
counterclockwise up high and slightly
over to our left we're next going to
look out for the point when the POI
passes through the bottom of its path
next time the POI passes through here go
ahead and move your hand straight out to
the left at shoulder height and pull the
POI into spinning horizontal plane
spinning clockwise if you're looking
down on it from above here we're going
to want to wind up with the hand above
the POI plane and the POI spinning as it
hangs below the hand we're getting close
to done only two more segments to go as
our POI spins clockwise and horizontal
plane we're going to look for the moment
when the POI is spinning nearest to us
and Mark it the next time the POI passes
through this point we're going to bring
our hand down and slightly towards the
center to pull the POI into spinning
clockwise in a vertical plane and yes
we're back into that odd inside plane
here so be aware that the POI will wind
up spinning between your arm and your
body remember keep your POI short all
right final Bend you ready for it from
that weird inside plane we're gonna now
watch out for that spot where the POI
begins to spin upwards this should
happen right along your Center Line the
next time the POI passes through here
bring your hand down close to your waist
along your Center Line and shift the POI
back into a forward Buzz saw our hand is
going to wind up just to the right of
the POI plane but still pretty close to
our Center Line great job you made it
all the way around awesome so now that
we know all the component bends that go
into Pro Bend toroids we want to work at
performing fewer and fewer beats in each
spot start by performing three beats in
that forward Buzz saw spot bend the
plane around a wall plane
counterclockwise and hold there for
three Beats
then bend into horizontal Plane off to
your right spinning counterclockwise
when seen from above and hold for three
Beats
then bend to that weird inside plane
counterclockwise for three beats and
switch to the reverse Buzz saw on top
for three Beats
now Bend into wall playing
counterclockwise for three beats and
then into that clockwise horizontal
Plane off to the left for three Beats
switch back into the inside playing
counterclockwise for three beats and
finally back into that buzz saw on
bottom cool when that feels comfortable
switch to doing two beats Buzz saw on
bottom two beats while playing
counterclockwise two beats horizontal
plane counterclockwise
two beats counterclockwise inside plane
two beats reverse Buzz saw on top two
beats counterclockwise wall plane two
beats horizontal clockwise two beats
inside playing counterclockwise and
return to buzzsaw on bottom and when
that gets to feel comfortable stop in
each location to spin the POI only once
at this point you're performing the pro
Bend toroid now real quick the way that
I'm teaching this has also been known to
lead to a bit of misconception about how
this toroid is structured that I do want
to just take one moment to clear up
based on how I'm teaching you this you
might think that the structure of the
toroid looks something like this with
planes essentially hinging back and
forth between wall Buzz saw and
horizontal planes and make no mistake
the way I teach this does tend to point
to this conclusion but the truth of the
matter is that all the points where we
pass through wall plane or that inside
plane well they're kind of an illusion
see what's actually happening here is
that the plane is spinning through these
in between in positions and it just so
happens to be that as the POI spins
through those points it looks a lot like
spinning in wall plane even though it's
really not see if I were to teach it the
way that I've taught the other toroid
tutorials I've done the exercise of
working down to a single beat in each
spot should actually look more like this
instead the more accurate way to
visualize it is that you spin the POI
say three beats and that bottom Buzz saw
position and then swing the POI out and
around to land in the counterclockwise
horizontal plane and hang out there for
three Beats swing the POI out and around
to wind up in the reverse Buzz saw up
top for three Beats swing the POI out
and around to wind up in the clockwise
horizontal plane for three beats and
finally swing the POI out and around to
return to the bottom Buzz saw plane from
here we do two Beats at the bottom swing
around to counterclockwise horizontal
for two swing around to reverse Buzz saw
up top for two swing around to clockwise
horizontal for two and return to forward
Buzz saw on bottom and finally go from
bottom to horizontal to top to
horizontal and back to bottom again to
complete the pattern so then why don't I
teach it this way to begin with why do I
teach it in a way that's more likely to
lead to those misconceptions well in all
honesty it's because I think that just
teaching each of these bends is hard
enough as is I'd Rather somebody get
down all of the pieces than harp on them
for visualizing it improperly and now
that we've got the full Trick In Our
Heads there are actually some really
cool patterns that we can pull out of it
for example just like in anti-bend the
direction of the POI seems to change it
each of the four major Compass points of
this trick I've described isobend as
having any and outie variations whereas
anti-bend switches between any and Audi
in each segment likewise probins also
switch from Audis to anys the way I've
outlined the method for this probe end
it's an Audi on the top and bottom and
in any on either side and if we look at
the trick from the side there's also a
pattern to the transits where we pass
through wall and inside planes in
between each of those four Compass
points we alternate between wall inside
wall inside as we go around pretty cool
huh you can imagine that both because
they're probably the most difficult
toroid to conceptualize as well as the
one that requires the most steps to
learn proband toroids are definitely the
rarest of all the toroids I've only seen
maybe a couple demos of them my own
included but you know what let's change
that State of Affairs now that I've put
this information Nation out there I want
to see more proband toroids out in the
world show me yours when you learn this
one post video of yourself doing it to
YouTube or Instagram and make sure to
tag me I would love to see your hard
work and as with all things POI related
learn this trick going both directions
and with both hands and yes learn how to
put the two hands together to perform it
in together same together opposite split
Time same direction and split time
opposites all the greatest hits did you
get anything out of this video please
leave me a like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
and to help my channel grow
[Music]
thank you
it takes a lot of support to make a
video and a channel like this one
possible so I would love to single out
some folks who've stepped up to make
that happen first up the friends of the
channel dark monk fire Mecca flow fests
flow toys juggling calling pyro Terra
light toys spin balls and Ultra POI to
learn more about what all these awesome
companies are doing to support flow
artists like yourself check out the
links that I have down in the
description and a special shout out to
the non-business friend of the channel
That is Becca beckonen thank you so much
for your support I also want to shout
out my wonderful flow patrons for
supporting this video and the channel
without their support none of this would
be possible I have it patreon so if
you'd like to sign up to support my work
please go check it out over at
patreon.com
drexfactor POI and if you dug this video
and would like to see more of my videos
on toroids I'm going to leave a link to
a playlist of said videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
for you to check out thank you so much
for watch make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace